Dear Mr. Chairman
dear friend Welcome to Russia, Moscow,
I am glad to have the opportunity to personally congratulate you on your
re-election as the head of the Chinese
state, this has become possible
due to the fact that the Chinese people and their
representatives have appreciated
your work over the previous decades,
China has made a
tremendous leap forward in recent years  in its
development
all over the world, it causes genuine
interest and we even envy you a little. we
carefully read your
proposals for resolving the island of the
crisis in Ukraine, of course, we will have the
opportunity to discuss the issue, we know that you
proceed from the principles of justice and
respect for fundamental
international law, indivisible
security
that we  always open to the negotiation
process
[music]